guatemala sigue bloqueando a los
migrantes que partieron desde honduras
la semana pasada luego de que el fin de
semana los atacaran con palos y bombas
lacrimógenas aproximadamente 2000
personas acamparon en una carretera
cerca de la población de vado hondo a 55
kilómetros de la frontera entre los dos
países
y hoy las autoridades los sacaron del
lugar el gobierno de guatemala defiende
sus acciones diciendo que no sólo se
trata de emigrantes
todos nos informaron anoche mismo que
habían infiltrado
elementos de manás de honduras y de
crimen organizado
sin embargo los integrantes de la
caravana aseguran que salieron de
honduras para huir de la pobreza no
trabajo no hay nada
después del nuevo choque algunos
hondureños regresaron a valhondo para
buscar rutas alternativas y lograr
llegar a eeuu pero no será un camino
fácil en mexico el gobierno desplegó
militares en la frontera desde el
viernes y paralelamente el presidente
espera que haya cambios en la política
de migración de eeuu
en la campaña del presidente de byd en
el ofreció
llevar a cabo una reforma migratoria y
yo espero
qué
se cumplan
ese ofrecimiento
se estima que por lo menos 9 mil
personas cruzaron a guatemala la semana
pasada en la que es la primera gran
caravana de migrantes centroamericanos
de 2021